Jean-Pierre rafarin est l'invité de
preuve par 3 bonsoir Monsieur le Premier
Ministre bonsoir Monsieur gross et merci
d'être avec nous et de nous réserver
d'ailleurs votre première réaction au
plan choc dévoilé dimanche soir par
François Hollande pour atteindre donc le
cap des 3 % de déficit public l'an
prochain et faire reculer le chômage dès
l'année prochaine l'UMP a refait on l'a
vu son unité le temps des CR contre
l'exécutif mais la compétition bien sûr
se poursuit pour la présidence du parti
Frédéric du Moulin de l'Agence France
Presse notre partenaire vous interrogera
tout à l'heure sur votre soutien à
Jean-François Copé et puis 3è partie de
preuve par 3 avec Perin Tarnaud de
Public Sénat on prête à la droite
l'ambition de regagner le Sénat dès 2014
premières élections intermédiaires avec
les municipales je note que les
téléspectateurs peuvent également
intervenir durant cette émission par le
biais de l'application TV check de notre
partenaire orange alors François
Hollande c'est-il selon vous monsieur
rafarin réveillé des deux yeux que d'un
œil disiez-vous avant son intervention
sur TF1 moi j'ai trouvé franchement que
l'émission n'était pas mauvaise je pense
que la dimension économique du discours
du président a été
renforcée je pense que ce qu'il a pu
voir cet été et l'aggravation de la
crise l'ont convaincu qu'il fallait
muscler le discours économique ce qui a
été fait il y a encore beaucoup à faire
mais je dois reconnaître que de ce point
de vue là j'ai trouvé la bataille
engagée contre la dette contre le
chômage c'était un discours clair je
regrette beaucoup l'absence du mot
Europe ah on le posé la question enfin
on n pas besoin de poser la question
quand on parle de la crise pour savoir
qu'aujourd'hui le sujet essentiel c'est
Europe euro emploiir emploi et Europe
c'est le même sujet sur la bataille
d'ailleurs François Laurand lui-même a
dit qu'il était en situation de combat
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des armes
qu'il va utiliser c'est-à-dire quand
même une pression fiscale accrue de
manière historique je pense et puis
également des économies budgétaires je
pense qu'il fait une erreur pédagogique
en ne coupant pas la poire en deux entre
l'État et la fiscalité et tant qu'à
chercher 30 milliards je pense qu'il
aurait cherché 15 milliards dans
l'économie de l'État et 15 milliards par
la fiscalité à partager entre les
entreprises et les ménages su été plus
convaincant là on sent que l'État fait
un effort mais c'est l'effort qui est
finalement la moitié de l'effort des
Français ça n'oindrit pas quand même le
satisfait site que vous délivrez ce soir
ce n'est pas un satisfait site je ne
suis pas satisfait je trouve que on a
perdu beaucoup de temps je trouve que la
France perd du temps en ce moment je
pense que le prés je pense que le
président doit aujourd'hui être plus
actif plus engagé y compris sur la scène
européenne mais je dis très clairement
que ce n'est l'intérêt de personne que
le Président de la République dans la
situation de crise dans laquelle nous
sommes fasse des contreperformances à la
télévision d'ord vous dites on perd du
temps il faut se réveiller mais si nous
en sommes là Jeanpierre affarin c'est
que la dérive vient de loin et même
depuis 2002 on a vu la dette s'envoler
le déficit se creuser hein est-ce que la
droite doit quand même reconnaître sa
part de responsabilité avant même la
crise il est il est clair que la crise a
été très importante je pense que nous
avons fait un certain nombre d'efforts
nous avons connu un certain nombre de
difficultés
mais je crois vraiment que dans ces 100
jours pour le Président il y a beaucoup
de temps perdu et je pense que il n'y a
pas de lisibilité sur son combat
européen que veut-il il voit Madame
Merkel oui il voit monsieur Monti oui il
va en Espagne oui mais pour dire quoi où
est le combat clair il faut évidemment
aujourd'hui mutualiser nos dettes mais
il faut faire des efforts quel est
l'effort de la France qui est fait pour
crédibiliser sa parole et notamment
l'objectif de 3 % de rédu déficit cette
crédibilité il faut le dire à Madame
Merkel il faut pouvoir dès le début de
l'été clairement envoyer le message à
nos partenaires et au marché à ceux qui
ont fait confiance à la France en lui
prêtant de l'argent qu'on va vraiment
réformer et là on a entendu l'annonce de
dépenses nouvelles l'annonce d'un
certain nombre de de perspectives qui
sont des perspective lente ça a été tout
ce message de l'été et et même le
message de la rentrée on va trouver pour
l'éducation des moyens nouveaux et où
va-t-il les trouver monsieur ces moyens
nouveaux et donc on a entendu un certain
nombre de discours laxistes je pense
qu'il est grand temps d'avoir un langage
de vérité le président a fait un tout
petit bout du chemin je m'en réjouis
mais il faut qu'il aille beaucoup plus
alors certains économistes de tout bord
d'ailleurs disent que il faut peut-être
revoir cet objectif de réduction du
déficit public parce que ça nous mène
tout droit à l'austérité c'est une
crainte je pense que cette analyse là
n'est pas exacte je pense que la crise
elle va venir de manière extrêmement
brutale quand les taux d'intérêt vont
monter c'est-àdire quand la France va
être dans la situation où il y aura plus
de confiance j'ai lu la presse
internationale l'affaire Arnaud est
dévastatrice pour l'image de la France
dans le monde c'est du niveau des 35
heur parce que si ce qui est un grand
groupe comme Dior comme toutes les
grandes marques de ce groupe LVMH n'a
pas confiance dans la France comment
voulez-vous que les autres aient
confiance dans la France et je vous
assure regardez la presse asiatique la
presse américaine on a le sentiment
comme dit Jean-Pierre chevedem les
élites n'ont plus confiance dans la
France on se dit les entrepreneurs n'ont
plus confiance dans la France qu'est-ce
que vous dites vous à Bernard arud le
patron de LVMH pour qu'il reste
pleinement en France je pense que le le
message de son attachement à la France a
été envoyé je pense qu'il doit être en
permanence réaffirmé il est clair que la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes de
scepticisme sur l'avenir de la France y
compris de la part des élites de la
France est extrêmement grave on mesure
pas combien l'étranger aujourd'hui nous
regarde et n'oublions pas que notre
dette contrairement à la dette japonaise
c'est une dette qui est à l'étranger et
si l'étranger on veut qu'ils ai
confiance au moins nous affichons notre
confiance avoir créé les conditions qui
ont conduit Monsieur Arnaud à faire
cette déclaration c'est une
responsabilité certes de Monsieur Arnaud
mais pas seulement alors françisand a
bien précisé que il maintenait donc
cette taxation des trait très ha revenu
au-dessus du million d'euros à 75 % vous
vous critiquez cette mesure même si
est provisoire et qu'elle est faite au
nom du patriotisme par le chef de l'État
je je pense que cette mesure a des
conséquences sur le plan économique qui
démobilise nos élites économiques et que
c'est vraiment très grave et quand je
vois un grand quotidien comme libération
qui tite casse-toi richcon j'ai vraiment
mal à mon bon sens et à l'honneur du
pays mais j'ai aussi le sentiment qu'on
donne là une image de la France qui
n'aime pas la réussite qui n'aime pas le
succès et au fond c'est ce qui décourage
tout le monde de venir participer au
développement de notre pays et tout ça
ça conduit à quoi à un risque
d'augmentation des taux d'intérêt et le
jour où nos taux d'intérêt augmenteront
et bien nous serons dans une extrême
difficulté financière alors le chef de
l'État a présenté son agenda social hein
avec à la clé d'ici la fin de l'année il
l'a dit des réformes de structure il
veut un choc de compétitivité d'autres
mesures sont annoncées en débat
d'ailleurs déjà au Parlement c'est par
exemple les les emplois d'avenir est-ce
que vous y êtes favorable pour les
jeunes qui ne sont pas ou peu qualifiés
je ne suis pas favorable à ce projet
mais je voterai le texte de loi je ne
suis pas favorable parce que j'aurais
été favorable à d'autres projets et je
l'ai déjà dit pendant la campagne
électorale il y a une solution qui me
paraissait meilleure qui était de
conditionner les allègements de charges
liés aux 35 he que don on bénéficier les
grands groupes de conditionner ces
allègements de char à l'embauche de
jeunes en alternance dans des vrais
entreprises avec de vrais emplois
c'était ça notre perspective c'était ça
ma conviction mais je ne vais jamais
voter contre un texte qui donne des
emplois à des jeunes je ne vais pas
mettre un barrière sur un chemin que je
sais difficile je sais qu'aujourd'hui
une première expliance ce n'est pas
forcément un emploi mais c'est une
marche vers l'emploi et donc de ce point
de vue-là je me ne sens pas je me sens
pas le droit d'interdire cet accès des G
donc je voterai ce texte j'aurais fait
autrement mais ce n'est pas une solution
mais c'est une marche vers l'emploi et
je me sens pas le droit de de m'opposer
à cette démarche alors qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de l'incohérence de certains
élus MP qui veulent voter contre les
emplois d'avenir mais qui veulent
localement les utiliser dans leur
collectivité ben écoutez j'ai vu ça avec
les socialistes j'ai vu ça dans tout le
débat politique quand on a un peu
d'expérience on sait qu'il vaut mieux
mettre ses votes au Parlement en
cohérence avec son action locale moi je
sais que sur le terrain dans ma
permanence quand je voudrais proposer à
des jeunes en difficulté d'aller
chercher un emploi d'avenir vaut mieux
que j'ai voté le texte plutôt que je
sois hostile au texte qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du Paris du chef de l'État qui
mise sur une inversion de la courbe du
chômage dans un an alors que la
croissance nécessaire n'est pas ne sera
pas au rendez-vous il ne prend pas les
moyens de ses objectifs il prend un
risque politique majeur pour vous je
pense qu'il prend un risque politique
majeur mais je crois que d'une manière
générale et cet été un peu léthargique
du gouvernement me laisse p c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas pris conscience de l'ampleur
de la crise qui nous attend avec les
difficultés majeures dans un grand
nombre d'entreprises quand on voit que
on a eu des discours sur PSA que c'était
ces licenciements étaient inacceptables
et qu'on voit ensuite que ré aujourdui
on essaie de limiter la ce la réalité
s'impose aux uns et aux autres je pense
que le gouvernement doit être conscient
de cela et je pense qu'il faut aider les
entreprises il faut aider les PME et je
vais vous le dire on n plus beaucoup
d'argent aujourd'hui dans l'état pour
aider les entreprises alors leur qu'on
les aide en allégeant les charges les
contraintes les normes les procédures
par exemple il y a des seuils à 50
comportte ces seuils de 50 à 100 faisons
en sorte qu'on donne des libertés aux
entreprises et il y a un certain nombre
de libertés qui ne coûte rien à l'état
est-ce que vous avez vu dimanche soir
François Hollande tourner la page de la
présidence normale on l'a vu he assez
autoritaire martial même et même on peut
s'interroger sur la place aujourd'hui du
Premier ministre non je pense que le
président a fait une émission en bon
professionnel mais je n'ai pas trouvé
qu'en terme de leadership il avait
encore atteint l'ensemble des
caractéristiques de la fonction et donc
je pense que il est en train
d'apprivoiser la fonction oui mais enfin
je n'ai pas trouvé que se dégager le
leadership dont le pays a besoin en
période de crise et je pense que
l'organisation institutionnelle de notre
pays n'est pas encore stabilisée je
pense que le rôle du Premier ministre le
rôle des ministres sont pas encore
aujourd'hui suffisamment stabilisé pas
suffisamment opérationnel et votre
commentaire sur la façon qu'à monsieur
HRO d'occuper la fonction de Premier
ministre monsieur rafarin je pense que
Monsieur hos doit définir clairement ce
qu'il apporte mais c'est quelqu'un de
respectable c'est quelqu'un qui a de
l'expérience il est maire de Nantes il a
présidé le groupe socialiste donc ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui qui est léger
dans la fonction mais c'est quelqu'un je
crois n'a pas encore défini ce qui doit
apporter véritablement à cette équipe
moi je m'attendais à ce qu'il soit un
peu un leader en ma de relation
franco-allemande or c'est le sujet
numéro 1 de l'été c'est le sujet numéro
1 de la crise et là très peu d'action
très peu d'initiative on peut je vois
qu'il fait une une percée à à Marseille
en s'y instant 48h il peut jouer comme
moi c'était le cas la carte de l'élu
provincial du maire parmi les maires de
quelqu'un qui est élu sur le terrain je
pense qu'il peut trouver des voix de
singularité pour
montrer sa mission je ne lui donne PAS
de conseil ce que je dis c'est que
pendant l'été le gouver ouvernement n'a
pas donné le sentiment d'être au travail
et on avait le sentiment qu'ils avaient
eu 10 ans pour prendre des vacances et
là on les a trouvé l'étargique je ne
sais pas mais mon petit doigt me dit que
votre préféré au sein du gouvernement
c'est Manuel
Vals c'est quelqu'un qui est respectable
mais non mais mcovis non mais il y a des
gens il y a des gens corrects il y a des
gens probablement incapables il il y a
un certain nom de gens qui sont pas forc
poursuit la même politique non en
matière de sécurité il a déclaré
aujourd'hui que la France ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère de l'Europe
et donc fermet elu vis-à-vis des Romes
oui ça c'était une déclaration de Michel
recard qu'on a beaucoup qu'on a beaucoup
cité par la suite donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a des qualités mais enfin il est
plus facile de se faire bien voir en
faisant une politique de droite qu'une
politique de gauche et c'est à à
l'intérieur notamment et c'est ce que
Vals est en train de mesurer et donc je
comprends qu' là il y a une réaction
intelligente il va là où il y a une
demande et en sette rentré est-ce que le
Holland baching vous a paru plus violent
que le que la sarcophobie à l'époque oh
je trouve que le gouvernement s'est
donné quelques attitudes qui ont conduit
à ce résultat et donc quand le cheval
trébuche c'est toujours le cavalier qui
est responsable donc il faut pas accuser
les chevaux mais le cavalier doit
pouvoir mener une allure qui évite les
critiques allez nous allons parler
maintenant de la compétition pour la
présidence de l'UMP monsieurarin fréri
du Moulin de l'Agence France Presse va
nous rejoindre mais d'abord la campagne
acharnée dominé donc par ce duel Copé
Fillon avec Paul
Bouffard c'est une
qui ébranle l'UMP depuis plusieurs
semaines les candidats à la présidence
du parti ont fait de cette course un
véritable pugila tout le monde veut être
l'héritier du sarkozisme dans la course
à la présidence les chefs se font la
guerre d'un côté Jean-François Copé le
secrétaire général de l'UMP continue
d'attaquer l'ancien Premier ministre lui
s'oppose au candidat des barons de l'UMP
Jean François a raison de se poser en
candidat du peuple militant du peuple
militant qui n'a pas se laisser dicter
de choix par les sondages sur les
sympathisants et cetera dans le camp
Fillon on estime que la ligne jaune est
franchie par Jean-François Copé c'est
vrai que ces derniers temps un grand
nombre d'élus ont rejoint la candidature
de François Fillon et appelé à soutenir
cette candidature mais si ces élus
appelle à soutenir François c'est
peut-être tout simplement qu'ils
écoutent leurs militants et peut-être
tout simplement que François Fillon est
le chouchou de leurs militants et au
milieu de ce duel à couteau tiré la
démocratie a du mal à trouver sa place
plusieurs ténors du parti interpellent
le secrétaire général sur l'organisation
de la campagne sur les conditions du
scrutin certains des petits candidats
tentent d'exister pour eux difficile de
faire entendre leur projet bien entendu
je suis un petit candidat je n'ai pas la
notoriété d'un François Fillon ou d'un
Jean-François Copé c'est normal les
petites phrases du camp Fillon contre le
camp Copé du camp Copé contre le camp
Fillon moi c'est pas ma tasse de thé
débat d'homme plutôt que débat d'idée
pour l'instant l'UMP est loin de l'unité
l'air de rien à l'arrivée le 18 ou le 25
novembre théoriquement on se rassemble
bah si on continue comme ça le
rassemblement va être
difficile voilà et donc nous sommes
encore loin de la ligne d'arrivéein et
le combat est apre bonsoir Frédéric du
Moulin de l'Agence France Presse qui
suitir monsieur cette compétitionir
monsieurouin comment allez-vous
présidence de très bien justement on l'a
vu dans le reportage la campagne
officielle n'a pas encore commencé et on
voit déjà que c'est très tendu entre les
deux camps principaux c'està-dire Fillon
et Copé euh certains parlent même d'une
bataille un peu à la Chirac baladure ça
vous fait penser à ça aussi ou pas il y
a un peu de ça oui il y a une campagne
très terrain très contact personnel puis
une campagne plus
médiatique je dirais qu'il y a une
campagne celle de François Fillon qui
est plus présidentielle et une campagne
de Jean-François Copé qui est plus
municipale oui et donc s'il y a un
parallèle entre avec Chirac Baladur vous
verriez plutôt Jean-François Copé dans
le rôle de Chirac on ne refit pas on ne
se baigne jamais de fois dans le même
fleuve mais au total c'est vrai c'est
vrai que il est clair que Jean-François
Copé a a une attitude de faire de la
politique un peu comme Jacques Chirac
c'est-à-dire dans la chaleur humaine
dans la convivialité dans le contact
vous aviez dit d'ailleurs au mois de au
mois de juillet vous aviez dit il y a du
Chirac en lui c'est ça absolument il a
ce côté et quand on voit son équipe je
voyais ce matin travailler c'est une
équipe qui est très jeune d'ailleurs qui
est beaucoup plus jeune que l'équipe
Fillon je crois au total et c'est en
plus une équipe qui est lié par un lien
affectif et vous pensez qu'au final il y
aura finalement que deux candidats ou
alors
il peut y en avoir d'autreson je si
c'était pas le cas est-ce que ça serait
vraiment un problème écoutez je j'ai
bien entendu tous ceux qui regrettent
qu'il y a un duel mais tous Cuxa ont
notamment participé à à nos statuts et
qui sont complètement inspirés par la
famille de notre construction qui était
la famille très attachée aux
institutions de la 5e République et on a
choisi à l'UMP des institutions comme la
5e République c'est-à-dire un duel avec
deux candidats au second tour et deux
candidats seul ement donc de toute façon
notre débat se terminera par un duel
puisqu'il n'y a que deux candidats au
second tour alors qu'on en est trois
qu'on en est qure moi je ne suis pas
cont c'est un problème démocratique au C
toute façon nous avons pris les
institutions de la 5e République elles
sont démocratiques et un scrutin
présidentiel à deux tours avec deux
candidats au second tour c'est ce qui
est dans nos institutions un mot ti sur
ce qui se passe au partis socialiste
puisqu'on critique beaucoup le manque de
démocratie enfin dans la procédure à
l'UMP qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
façon qu' a retenu le Parti socialiste
qui dem annoncera donc le successeur de
Martin Aubri écoutez je pense que c'est
une affaire qui se traite entre notaes
entre baron dirait-on aujourd'hui et pas
entre militants donc c'est regrettable
au moins je pense que l'élection de
l'UMP et le congrès de l'UMP va être
décidé par les militants et pas par les
notables donc de ce point de vue-là je
pense que l'UMP est plus militante et
plus dans la proximité que le Parti
socialiste mais je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur un point très
important de notre conrès pour moi
l'élection présidentielle du l'UMP est
importante mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel
pourquoi parce que de toute façon le
candidat qui sera élu devra être
rééligible dans 3 ans et que quant au
choix du candidat à la présidentielle il
devra être choisi par des primaires en
2016 donc pour moi le plus important au
Congrès c'est le rassemblement par les
motions de courant qui vont être créés
et je peux vous annoncer ce soir que le
courant humaniste centriste libéral a
réussi à se rassembler on présentera une
motion demain et donc que de
jean-léonetti à Marc Philippe d'bress en
passensant par Luc Chatel Marc lafiner
avec donc toute cette famille qui est
une famille non seulement des centristes
des libéraux mais aussi des gens comme
Marie-Hélène desgau ou André qui sont
des Gaulistes sociaux nous avons là une
motion qui rassemble plus de 80
parlementaires plus de 80 parlementaires
ce sera sans doute une motion par parmi
les plus larges qui sera présenté et de
ce point de vue-là je pense que ce sera
l'innovation de ce Conz bien normalement
vous devriez avoir un bon score vous
pensez au moment je pense que notamment
en ayant rapproché la motion que je
conduisais avec celle que conduisait Luc
châel je pense que nous devrions faire
un bon score et c'est très important je
vois que tout le monde n'est pas
favorable au mouvement dans l'UMP je
vois que François Fillon est hésitant
j'ai entendu que Nathalie que j'aime
beaucoup être contre les courants moi je
pense que la survie l'avenir de de l'UMP
passe par les courants et par la
diversité sans courant l'unité de l'UMP
serait mise en cause mais vous pensez
justement que le courant humaniste
libéral centriste est majoritaire à
l'UMP je ne pense pas qu'il soit
majoritaire nous verrons mais en tout
cas il peut-être celui qui arrivera en
tête dans l'UMP nous avons comme
ambition d'être le courant qui arrivera
en tête dans l'UMP c'est une bataille
difficile mais nous avons devant la
Droite populaire et devant le je je
pense que en tout cas nous nous battons
pour la première h nousésent la France
moderne et humaniste et cette France
moderne et humaniste dans l'UMP a
l'espoir d'être le premier courant mais
le candidat que vous ne soutenez pas
donc François Fillon a mis en garde
contre une balcanisation de l'UMP en
raison de ces courants que vous défendez
oui mais je pense que moi je mets en
garde contre une uformisation une
caporalisation de l'UMP et donc je ne
crois pas que l'alignement de l'UMP sur
un seul courant historique soit vraiment
l'avenir de l'UMP je pense que nous
sommes assez responsables pour faire de
notre diversité une capacité d'unité et
moi je pense que le choix des courants
est un choix stratégique je fais
confiance à jean-françis Copé non
seulement c'est mon ami il a été mon
ministre c'est un élément politique
objectif c'est lui qui veut créer les
courants c'est lui qui a une vision
originale d'une famille politique qui
doit assumer sa complexité et c'est pour
ça qu'il peut compter sur mon soutien
n'a jamais été votre ami j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec lui on a fait beaucoup de
choses ensemble mais en l'occurrence je
choisis la jeune génération je pense que
la génération qui est la mienne qui a
quelques expérience doit participer au
renouvellement de l'UMP il y a autour de
Jean-François Copé une équipe très jeune
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour Luc châel je
vois qu'il y a là un potentiel et je
crois que pour préparer l'avenir la vie
politique c'est très dur exercer des
responsabilités au sommet d'État c'est
très difficile il faut se préparer et
pour ça il faut choisir les jeunes mais
justement c'est lui que vous soutenez et
est-ce que vous pensez que les sondages
qui sont quand même très fortement en
faveur de Monsieur Fillon ils sont
réalisés sur les sympathisants est-ce
que vous faites partie des gens qui
faitent une réelle distinction entre les
sympathisants et les militants seuls les
militants étant amenés à voter au moment
du Congrès d'abord je vous dirais que
dans ma vie politique j'ai toujours
choisi mes convictions avant les
sondages quand j'ai choisi giscar Chirac
et Sarkozi pour la présidentiel tous les
trois étaient en retard dans les
sondages donc c'est pas le sondage qui
fait ma conviction c'est ma conviction
qui m'engage
pour cela je crois que c'est vrai que
sympathisants et militants il faut faire
une différence c'est vrai que d'une
manière générale je dirais que plus on
fréquente la permanence de l'UMP dans la
circonscription plus on est proche de
Jean-François copopé plus on est proche
du travail de terrain du travail
militant plus on est proche de
Jean-François Copé et plus on s'éloigne
vers des fonction plus notable plus
sympathisante plus plus élu peut-être un
peu plus lointaine plus on est Fillon
donc je pense estce que vous jusqu'à
dire comme certains
copéisteson mais mais je suis mais mais
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
vous êtes blond que vous n'aimez pas les
bruns bon donc chacun a son profil mais
on peut être quelqu'un ouvert moi il
m'arrive d'aimer ce que je ne suis
pasrez-vous et donc il m'arrive d'être
ouvert aux autres et donc là moi je peux
vous dire je suis en effet un baron mais
il se trouve que je suis aussi j'ai le
cœur militant et en tout cas je choisis
l'avenir et je choisis la jeune
génération mais est-ce que vous diriez
vous aussi que Copé c'est le candidat
des militants et franç Fillon le
candidat des des barons justement ça a
été dit redit j'ai de l'estime et du
respect pour François Fillon c'est
quelqu'un qui a des grandes capacités et
il a dans ses équipes et des militants
et des barons donc que tout ça est une
question de dosage je ne veux pas en
rajouter sur ce sujet en tout cas nous
voulons après cette campagne rassembler
tout le monde donc je ne veux pas de
phrase définitive mais je vous l'ai dit
et je me suis suffisamment engagé pour
vous dire très clairement que pour moi
Jean-François Copé pouvait être un
avenir et que je pense qu'il a des
chances de gagner les différences de
fondin on les saisit pas forcément
franchement très important parce que
vous savez on vient vous vous souvenez
du RPR de l'UDF vous vous souvenez de de
de ces batailles politiques rassembler
dans une
famille non pas sur une ligne politique
monoliique et qui pourrait à un moment
ou un autre caporaliser tout le monde
c'est un risque mais vous voulez dire
que par exemple moi j'ai pas trouvé
suffisamment dans les équipes
gouvernementales de Nicolas Sarkozi et
François Fillon je n'ai pas trouvé assez
de diversité la même famille politique
historique a été très représenté dans
toute l'histoire de ces 5 dernières
années moi je pense qu'à l'avenir il
faut travailler davantage toutes les
diversités mais vous craignez justement
que si François Fillon était élu ces
courant ne soit pas je ne crains rien si
François Fillon est élu si François
Fillon est élu la démocratie l'aura
choisi et il sera le président donc il
est clair que je n'ai pas peur n de
crainre mais je pense que la diversité
elle passe par les courants et ce que je
constate c'est que Jean-François Copé if
favorable et que François Fillon est
plutôt rés on a cité Nicolas mais c'est
en fait le un peu le fantôme de cette
élection est-ce que vous vous pensez que
il va
revenir écoutez il ne me paraît pas
absent j'ai le sentiment qu'il
s'intéresse toujours à la politique et
j'entends beaucoup de gens sur le
terrain qui font référence à lui y
compris d'ailleurs le nouveau
gouvernement qui a du mal à sortir de
son face- à face avec Nicolas Sarkozi
donc je pense que Nicolas Sarkozi reste
en effet dans notre paysage politique
est-ce que ce sera bien pour lui est-ce
que ce sera bien pour le pays le temps
le dira il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour écoutez je peux avoir des contacts
avec lui je suis en situation où les uns
et les autres peuvent me parler de lui
donc je ne suis pas vraiment en état de
manque non est-ce qu'il manque au débat
politique dans ce pays bah je pense que
il a créé quand même une forme de
gouvernement liée au courage lié à
l'audace lié à l'énergie qui fait que
quand on voit un gouvernement partir en
vacances on se dit tiens pour la Géorgie
il était il avait arrêté ses vacances
tiens il avait pris des options
courageuses sur tel ou tel sujet c'estàd
que jamais Nicolas Sarkozi était
indifférent à l'actualité on avait un
peu le sentiment cet été que l'exécutif
était un peu aux abonnés ABS mais de
manière générale est-ce que vous croyez
au retour des hommes providentiels
vous je pense que les circonstances vont
tellement vite je pense que les la
situation politique devient tellement
complexe que les jeunes générations
aujourd'hui arrivent dans notre société
je pense en effet que l'aspiration au
renouvellement risque d'être dominant
mais personne ne peut savoir dans quelle
situation nous serons et en plus je
pense que la crise que nous avons devant
nous qui est devant nous c'est pour ça
que tout à l'heure je regrettais que le
gouvernement ne plaçait pas la crise
vraiment au bon niveau c'est-à-dire au
niveau européen et pas seulement au
niveau des emplois jeunes bien sûr au
niveau de la flexibilité bien sûr mais
d'abord au niveau européen je pense que
dans ce contexte là de crise on peut
avoir besoin de recours ça s vu dans le
passé merci frédrique du moulin un mot
peut-être sur de votre successeur
Dominique de Villepin qui a été entendu
mis en garde à vue d'ailleurs un temps
par les gendarmes dans l'affaire des
relais château il est soupçonné d'avoir
exercé des pressions en faveur de son
ami Régis Bulot qui était le dirigeant à
l'époque de cette chaîne hôtelière et
qui lui-même est soupçonné d'avoir
procédé à des détournements de fonds à
ancien Premier ministre comme ça entendu
par les gendarmes écoutez je ne connais
rien à cette affaire que la justice
fasse son travail mais sur un plan
personnel ça peut pas être une nouvelle
qui me réjouisse perar de Public Sénat
donc va nous rejoindre maintenant pour
évoquer le Sénat maintenant Jean-Pierre
afarin objectif 2014 pour la droite
dit-on qui s'imagine déjà reprendre le
flambeau
tamtranui c'est la dur loi de la
politique aussitôt élu aussitôt Oni le
président et sa majorité font face à
l'impati des Français dont la déception
pointe déjà l'opposition se voit déjà
gagner les élections intermédiaires mais
le gouvernement averti ça ne se passera
pas comme ça il est tout à fait légitime
pour une formation politique d'avoir des
espoirs voilà ceci étant entre l'espoir
et la concrétisation il y a il y a
beaucoup de preuves à faire à l'égard de
celles et ceux qui vont voter pas encore
de preuve mais dans le groupe um du
Sénat on prédit des difficulté pour la
gauche horizon 2014 les élections
municipales en 2014 sont en effet
positionné à un moment du quinquena qui
devrait permettre à l'opposition de se
refaire des forces or les élections
municipales ont un impact immédiat sur
le sénatorial puisque la Haute Assemblée
est élue essentiellement par les
délégués des conseils municipaux
l'opposition prédit des difficultés pour
la majorité et a peu de chance de se
tromper 2014 c'est surtout le milieu du
mandat de François Hollande
traditionnellement le creux de la vague
dans un quinena présidentiel on sait
qu'au cours du quinena de Nicolas
Sarkozi les élections intermédiaire ont
pratiquement toutes été perdu par la
droite et peut-être que ces élections
intermédiaires signifieront un retour de
balencier en défaveur du parti au
pouvoir en défaveur de la gauche alors
le Sénat pourrait-il à nouveau tourner à
droite 3 ans seulement après son
basculement à gauche le Sénat de gauche
ne sera-t-il qu'une parenthèse dans
l'histoire de la Haute
Assemblée voilà per interna est avec
nous pine qui suit de très près
l'actualité sénatoriale et la rentrée a
été pour le moins houleuse ce mardi hein
exactement avant de parler des des
prochaines élections sénatoriales
Jean-Pierre rafarin cette ouverture très
agitée la session extraordinaire cet
après-midi au Sénat on a vu que les
appels au règlement se sont multipliés à
droite comme à gauche hein d'ailleurs
sur l'examen en urgence du texte sur le
logement est-ce que vous estimez que le
Sénat n'ait pas été assez respecté par
le gouvernement dans cette procédure bon
très franchement tous les gouvernements
ont tendance à vouloir un peu malmener
le Parlement et que la procédure
d'urgence on l'utilise beaucoup trop
quand j'étais Premier ministre j'ai
veillé à limiter un peu ce recours à
l'urgence il est clair que le Parlement
apprécie peu qu'on a des grandes
périodes sans texte qu'on a des grandes
périodes pratiquement sans travail et
que d'un seul coup on nous demande de
travailler dans l'urgence mais là les
sénateurs n'ont même pas eu le temps de
faire leur rapport sur ce texte qui est
une première dans l'histoire du Sénat
bien sûr c'est c'est un non respect du
Parlement et c'est je crois qu'on est en
train de payer cette léthargie estivale
où le le pouvoir a peu travaillé et
maintenant veut accélérer et tout ça
donne le sentiment d'être un peu impr
isé et complètement désorganisé mais
l'urgence pour le logement social a été
soulignée mais l'urgence on peut très
bien travailler vite mais dans
l'organisation et avec concertation et
je pense que il aurait pu être utile par
exemple de travailler sur ces sujets au
mois de juillet et on aurait pu
reprendre plutôt en septembre si on
devait reprendre mais au fond les textes
n'étaient pas prêts et donc on se trouve
dans une situation qui est une situation
d'improvisation sur le fond du texte
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à plus de
sanctions envers les maires qui ne
respectent pas les quotas de logements
sociaux sur leur commune écoutez c'est
très compliqué parce que ça va dépendre
de quel quotas est-ce qu'on passe à 25 %
et quel critères donc pour le
moment mais pas pasendant toutes les
circonstances et donc il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont en
discussion et et notamment de de voir en
fonction des ville l'écart par exemple
entre les loyers sociaux les loyers du
privé peut-être un paramètre d'arbitrage
donc j'attends de voir philosophie
générale est-ce que vous êtes favorable
quand même à plus de sanctions est-ce
qu'on incite les maires à construire man
générale je préfère qu'on incite h par
des avantages plôon de la répr on va
bien aider avec la mise à disposition
gratuite dit-on de terrain oui mais il
faudrait que les gouvernements soit un
peu plus clair qu'il ne l'a été jusqu'à
maintenant sur la la capacité à libérer
des terrains donc tout ceci est pas
préparé tout ceci est anticipé donc
j'attendrai la fin parle d'improvisation
finalement c'est c'est une improvisation
regrettable en tout cas c'est pas du bon
travail législatif sur l'ambiance au
Sénat dans une interview au Figaro il y
a de semaines Gérard Larcher a regretté
que le Sénat soit devenu la maison du
silence est-ce que vous partagez cette
position avec lui moi je trouve qu'on a
été silencieux parce qu'en effet pendant
toute cette période il y a pas eu
beaucoup de travail parlementaire mais
ce silence du Sénat avait comme premier
responsable l'exécutif le gouvernement
qui n'a pas donné des textes et en
général je me souviens quand j'étais
Premier ministre en 2002 mais je me
souviens après moi François Fillon je me
souviens y compris de de Lionel Jospin
en 97 les premiers les premières
semaines d'un nouveau pouvoir on met
tout de suite en œuvre par des textes
important et donc là on a eu le
sentiment qu'il y avait rien de très
important pendant ces 100 premiers jours
ou mais les parlementaires auraient pu
prendre l'initiative écoutez les
parlementairire mon fait il y a un grand
nombre de propositions de loi qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui au débat et que le
gouvernement n'inscrit pas à l'ordre du
jour donc je crois vraiment aujourd'hui
que le Parlement est prêt à travailler
mais que le gouvernement doit lui aussi
se mettre au travail en tout cas on voit
que Gérard Larcher se positionne
toujours en vue d'un éventuel bascul
basculement du Sénat à nouveau à droite
en 2014 est-ce que vousmême vous avez
encore des la ficelle qu'elle est belle
cette ficelle mais a marqué que je il y
a pas que le duel peut-être Copé Fillon
il y en a d'autres qui se pr de 2008 au
Sénat l'Arch écoutz nous nous verrons je
pense qu'il n'est pas ni cortois
vis-à-vis du président actuel qui est en
cours de son mandat de tout de suite
chercher à le déstabiliser il faut que
le Sénat fonctionne normalement donc je
trouve que le président du Sénat fait
fonctionner le Sénat comme il se doit
donc je n'ai pas àener une guerria
interne je pense d'autre par que au
lendemain d'une défaite électorale il
vaut mieux analyser les raisons de
l'échec que de partir aussitôt à la
conquête comme ça en disant maintenant
c'est à nous il faut être capable
d'avoir un discours qui va convaincre
les maires qui va nous permettre de
gagner les municipales d'avoir une
attitude au Parlement constructive et
c'est si nous sommes capables de dégager
ce message positif et constructif que
nous pourrons gagner des municipales et
envisager l'alternance au Cénat don
enore à l'analyse à l'analyse de la
défaite présidentielle mais je je pense
que la manière dont on a traité les élus
locaux la manière dont on a traité les
élus locaux tris 3 mois 6 mois avant les
élections
sénatoriales je l'avais je l'avais déjà
dit on a plutôt donné que perdu le Sénat
je me suis déjà exprimé sur ce sujet
donc je pense qu'un certain nombre
d'erreurs ont été faites il faudra les
corriger il faut respecter les
collectivités locales il faut avoir des
projets d'avenir et il faut que nous
nous soyons porteurs de ces projets donc
donc avec Gérard Larcher et avec les
autres nous devons construire ce projet
qui nous conduira peut-être à
l'alternance mais on fait pas de
l'alternance le préalable on fait du
projet le préalable mais pour éviter
cette alternance la majorité actuelle
pourrait modifier le mode de scrutin
nous nous attendons à tous les malices
de sa part donc on on pense en effet que
nous aurons quelques malices de modes de
scrutin qui seront changés avec par
exemple l'application prop quand j'ai vu
l'état du Parti socialiste quand ils ont
gagné Sénat je me doute qu'ils vont tout
faire pour essayer de ne point le perdre
donc ça nous nous certainement que nous
aurons des des situations assez
malicieuse avec un un changement de loi
électorale avec sans doute un certain
nombre d'artifices pour que la gauche
puisse conserver mais nous verrons ça le
moment venu moi je ne souhaite pas que
le Sénat dans cette période nouvelle
apparaisse comme un lieu de polémique
comme un lieu de tension nous sommes des
élus républicains notre pays dans une
situation très grave nous devons faire
fonctionner le Sénat nous devons
respecter les votes démocratiques et
nous devons n exprimer en liberté et
pour nous gens de l'opposition notre
travail n'est pas celui de la Guera
notre travail est de construire des
projets d'avenir et de nous montrer
crédiible vis-à-vis des Français pour
l'avenir et donc je ne suis pas
favorable à ce que tous les jours on
transforme le le Sénat en un champ de
bataille au contraire que ça soit plutôt
un champ d'avenir c'est pour ça que vous
voterez avec la gauche le traité
européen le texte sur le traité européen
bien bien sûr que je voterai le traité
européen je pense que c'est un texte
très important j'aurais préféré qu'on
ait la loi constitutionnelle plutôt que
la loi organique la loi organique elle
n'a pas la puissance qui aurait
convaincu et les Allemands et nos
partenaires y compris les marchés donc
je pense que là il y a une erreur mais
ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a une erreur
que je vais freiner la dynamique
européenne qui est nécessaire au pays
donc bien sûr que que je voterai ce
texte européen quand quand je dis que je
vote pour les emplois jeunes je les
emplois d'avenir maintenant je ne sais
pas parce que je partage cette mesure
mais à partir du moment où le décide le
le le président de la République élu de
manière à décider ce type d'initiative
moi sur le terrain je ne veux pas être
celui qui empêchera un certain nombre de
jeunes d'avoir accès à cette première
expérience donc ça ne veut pas dire que
j'adhère mais je suis un élu responsable
qui pense au français plus qu'au pouvoir
est-ce que vous adhérez au prochain
projet de loi pour limiter voir
interdire le cumul des mandats écoutez
ça c'est très difficile moi je pense que
vous savez je suis pas en situation de
cumulle moi je n'ai qu'un mandat donc je
pourrais être très facilement favorable
à ça mais en tout cas si notre pays
était très décentralisé je préférais
mais aujourd'hui tout se décide encore à
Paris notre pays n'est pas suffisamment
décentralisé et donc tant que le pays ne
sera pas suffisamment décentralisé je
souhaite que l'élu est un mandat
national et un mandat local mais estce
qu'il pourrait y avoir un statut
particulier pour les sénateurs par
rapport aux députés quiut ça para ça ne
me paraîtrait pas choquant je sais que
les députés sont pas du tout satisfaits
de cette idée mais ce que je trouve un
peu absurde c'est que le maire qui vote
pour le sénateur n'aurit pas le droit
d'être sénateur parce que le jour où est
sénateur il devient plus maire donc si
le maire qui est dans le corps électoral
quiit le sénateur n'a pas le droit
d'être sénateur ou s'il devient sénateur
il peut plus être maire je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui est paradoxal
nous sommes élus par les maires qu'on
puisse avoir un mandat de maire ne me
paraît pas du tout choquant bien au
contraire c'est une position forte au
sein du groupe socialiste notamment
défendu par François repsamen est-ce que
vous voterez le mariage gay ça nous en
discuterons moi je ne pense pas que je
le voterai je ne pense pas que je le
voterai nous nous en discuterons on va
on va voir un peu les uns et les autres
mais il s'agit là de sujets très
personnels des sujets de conviction sur
lesquels toutes les positions sont tout
à fait respectables et je pense qu'il
faut être dans une position très ouverte
moi la la difficulté que j'ai avec ce
sujet c'est que le mariage parce que je
suis catholique le mariage est un
sacrement pour quelqu'un de catholique
donc c'est un sujet sur l'appellation
donc c'est qui est un problème qui
mérite d'être débat mais je suis pas du
tout fermé à l'idée sociale du sujet
donc c'est un c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous débattrons et pour lequel moi moi
je n'ai pas de aucune crispation je
pense que c'est un notre société doit
les couples homosexuel je pense que
c'est à peu près un sujet de conviction
de cette nature comme comme on a eu des
des sujets qui sont des sujets d'éthique
des sujets de de morale des sujets qui
sont sur le plan social très important
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'il y ait
une liberté de conscience par exemple
dans la motion des des humanistes
libéraux que nous avons signé avec
jeanonetti Luc Chatel et quelques autres
sur ces sujetsl nous voulons respecter
la liber de vote de chacun Jean-Pierre
affarin une question avec notre
partenaire orange et l'application TV
check c'est une question de Irma vous
avez accepté une mission sur l'Algérie
pour Laurent fabus est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à soutenir Martine auri qui elle va
travailler sur la Chine vous qui êtes un
grand spécialiste de la Chine un grand
connaisseur de la Chine alors d'abord la
mission sur l'Algérie c'est la
prolongation d'une mission que m'avait
confié Nicolas Sarkozi il y a 2 ans et
pour lequel il y a encore quelques
travaux à faire à acheter donc j'ai
accepté de poursuivre cette mission et
j'ai appelé Martine Aubri pour lui dire
que j'étais tout à fait disposé à
travailler avec elle sur les relations
avec la Chine très souvent de manière
très positive nous nous verrons sans
doute prochainement dès qu'elle sera
libérée de ses fonctions partisanes très
partisanes dès qu'elle sera libérée nous
nous verrons ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que depuis très longtemps les
dirigeants chinois m'ont toujours dit
qu'ils souhaitaient avoir une
personnalité socialiste qui
s'intéressait aux relations
franco-chinoises il souffrai d'un
déficit de considération pour la Chine
laentag présid il y a pas dans
introduction
alors en tout cas je vais vous le dire
je mets la politique étrangère de mon
pays à l'extérieur des polémiques ce
sont des sujets difficiles qui ne se
règlent pas en un mandat et ce sont des
sujets sur lequels on doit avoir une
certaine distance vis-à-vis de la
polémique et si Madame auri peut faire
du travail utile pour la France en Chine
je ne vais pas l'empêcher d'agir bien au
contraire si je peux l'aider volontiers
et donc quand François Hollande se
rendra en Algérie vous participerez à ce
voyage officiel à ces côtés écz je n'ai
pas été invité le moment venu nous
verrons mais en tout cas je vous dis
très clairement je ne mets pas la
politique étrangère au cœur des
polémiques ce sont des sujets très
compliqués ce sont des sujets qui
demandent des années des années
d'expertise des mouvements historiques
qui sont très compliqués et je pense
qu'il faut vis-à-vis de l'État français
une continuité et en ce qui me concerne
je me réjouis de voir que dans la 5e
République globalement malgré les
alternances il y a une certaine cont a
pas que la politique étrangère que vous
mettez hors des polémiques je-pierre on
vous écoute depuis le début de cette
émission on l'a vu sur les emplois
d'avenir vous allez les voter vous êtes
associé vous soutenez Jean-François Copé
qui lui est partisan d'une opposition
vraent frontal hein presque violente
avec l'exécutif vous vous êtes quand
même un peu en en mar et ben je vais
vous dire il il a besoin de moi et moi
et moi j'ai besoin parce qu'il a besoin
de gens qui autour de lui ont des
attitudes des convictions et les
humanistes se sentent bien à côté de
Jean-François Copé même s'il y a des
humanistes comme Jean lonetti qui
soutiennent François mais donc moi je
pense que Jean-François Copé va
organiser les courants pour ça il est
adepte de la diversité et comme il est
généreux d'un côté mais très direct de
l'autre il est assez cach comme on dit
c'est assez facile d'être à ses côtés
c'est assez facile de faire en sorte
qu'il vous écoute très carré et vous
vous apportez des rondeurs exactement
vous avez tout devé c'est l'image qu'on
va retenir absolument et vim besoin de
vous et si je peux lui apporter aussi un
peu d'expérience et puis goû de l'avenir
que j'ai ce goût de l'International de
l'ouverture mais je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui rassemble il
est il est capable de réunir et au fond
c'est un bon manager c'est un bon chef
de parti je pense que la solitude n'est
pas bonne conseillère pour diriger une
famille politique merci beaucoup
jean-pierrefarin d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui vous étiez donc le premier
invité de la nouvelle saison de preuve
par 3 merci pine merci à nos partenaires
l'Agence France Presse et puis donc
l'application TV check d'orange et on se
retrouve ici même la semaine prochaine
bonsoir à
tous se renseigner sur les
programmes voir ou revoir les
émissions suivre le fil d'information
politique et
parlementaire pour vivre la politique en
temps réel connectez-vous et réagissez
sur
publsenat.fr
chaque année 70000 personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ces
hospitalisations vient d'être réformée
la réalisatrice laorine de bieux a
enquêté sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très
tabou je pense que la folie fait peur
encore aujourd'hui et que j'avais envie
de parler des des fractures de la
société ça en fait partie et je pense
que c'est une manière de de déécrire la
société que de de raconter comment la
société traite ses fous c'est un ang
important dit souvent des prisons aussi
c'est une façon aussi de voir quel est
le niveau d'une société exactement he de
voir comment elle gère à la marge les
personnes qui sont pas dans le circuit
de qui sont privé de liberté c'est un
enjeu important parce que il y a à peu
près 70000 personnes qui sont
hospitalisées sous contrainte par an et
que ça corres à peu près au nombre de
personnes qui sont incarcéré c'est
équivalent donc c'est vrai que c'est
comparable l'enjeu est important et il n
voilà il nous semblait important de
donner la parole aux personnes
concernées'estce qui est dur dans
l'histoire quand on est la mère d'un
enfant comme ça qu'on demande à à
hospitaliser c'est quoi c'est la
trahison qu'on semble lui faire c'est la
peur de se tromper c'est non là j'avais
pas peur de me tromper toute façon je
suis pas toute seule dans le une mère ne
peut pas hospitaliser son enfant de
force il y a pas la vie du psychiatre
donc il y a des médecins qui vous
appuient ou qui vous qui disent non ou
qui disent oui mais il y a pas que vous
vous vous le demandez mais bon ben ce
qui est c'est vous voyez votre enfant
partir dans une ambulance en ayant une
piiture calmante de force dans la fesse
voilà et vous suivez vous arrivez en
pleine nuit dans un
hôpital psychiatrique que ça soit
saintane ou pogirot ou d'autres c'est
quand même un peu style asile du 19e
siècle hein donc voilà ma fille me
disait tu m'as fait interner chez les
fous non je t'ai fait hospitaliser parce
que tu es malade et tu as besoin
d'acrocherimagine de N plus fois ou
c'est terrible pour pour avoir la
confiance après récupérer elle peut elle
comprend pas elle veut pas et puis petit
à petit petit à petit il y a quand même
une espèce de compréhension que ça n'est
pas vraiment pour lui faire du mal et
que elle y trouve aussi elle a fait la
démarche elle-même parfois aller seul
vous en êtes là aujourd'hui elle est en
hospitalation libre he comme on dit
c'est ça
elle choisit d'y aller oui donc c'est
une évolution dans son traînement et
dans son état oui exê donc elle a admis
qu'au fil du temps que vous ayez fait le
bon choix que d'appeler des médecins
pour la contraindre à se faire soigner
c'est ça oui oui en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisé à demande
d'un tiers ou d'office dans un hôpital
on n'est pas libre on est enfermé on est
contraint on est attaché on est dans
dans une chambre on est quoi on est
avant tout
protégé concrtement la vérité c'est quoi
pour protéger la vérité des faits mais
dans toute la médecine il y a des des
mesures qui sont prises quand qu'on
reçoit quelqu'un qui est à moiti dans le
Comat on va on va on va prendre toutes
les dispositions pour qu'il ne se fasse
pas de mal en tombant nous nous devons
faire en sorte que puisqu'il n'est pas
conscient des troubles dont il souffre
que il ne part il ne quitte pas
l'hôpital immédiatement qu'il ne ne se
fasse pas du mal qu'il ne fasse pas de
mal à d'autres patients enfin c'est
toutes ces mesures de j'ai parlis à to
tout à l'heure d'incarcération mais on
est on est quand même dans une logique
de privation de contrainte on peut
donner un traitement à quelqu'un qui le
refuseement à tous les usages hein et
toutes les règles on peut le voir sous
ce regard là mais pour moi pour moi
c'est la protection oui oui c'est une
protection nécessaire et et qui qui
n'est pas discutable l'arrivée du juge
c'est c'est très très difficile à vivre
pour les psychiatres qui jusqu'à présent
étit un peu maître chez chez eux et qui
sont maintenant obligés effectivement de
justifier encore une fois la privation
de liberté nous avons eu de longs débats
à l'Assemblée pour savoir si le juge
devait aussi intervenir dans
l'obligation de soin et il nous est
apparu nous députés toute tendance
politique confondue l'obligation de soin
à domicile à l'extérieur à l'extérieur
he qui est une nouveauté de la loi aussi
hein obliger les soins mais là il y a
pas le regard du juge pour l'instant
indépendamment voilà de de la privation
de liberté il nous a semblé que le juge
n'avait pas intervenir sur l'obligation
de soin ça c'est le rôle du médecin
c'est le rôle du psychiatre à côté de ça
la notion de privation de liberté elle
est fondamentale et ça ce n'est pas du
ressort du médecin c'est vraiment du
ressort du juge de la de la liberté
savoir
si patient est en mesure ou pas de
sortir alors ça se passe plus ou moins
bien selon que les juges se déplacent à
l'hôpital ou pas nous avons aujourd'hui
dans les les auditions que nous avons
mené le premier bilan montre qu'environ
30 % des juges se déplacent dans les
hôpitaux et dans ce cas-là ça se passe
globalement très bien est-ce qu'ils
comprennent bien que vous êtes de leur
côté et pas en face et comment ça se
passe est-ce qu'ils sont véhéments
est-ce qu' - qui revendique estce qui
c'est très c'est très c'est très
variable c'està dire que il il y a toute
une un certain nombre de patients qui
comprennent pourquoi ils sont là et
euh toute une autre partie qui n'est pas
d'accord d'ailleurs il y a eu
hospitalisation sans consentement c'est
bien qu'au départ le patient n'était pas
n'était pas consentant mais au bout de
15 jours parce que nous nous intervenons
quand même quasiment au bout de 15 jours
euh voilà pas toujours pas toujours tour
mais en tout cas en tout cas je vois
quand même un certain nombre de
personnes qui n'étaient pas d'accord
pour être hospitalisé qui 10 jours plus
tard adè VO jeis vous dire un mot qui va
vous choquer mais vous en libérez entre
guillemets combien alors c'est à peu
près 5 à 6 % 5 à 6 % de main levé
ouant je
vous évaluation en primaire enfants
stressés parents compétitifs l'école
est-elle en panne ils en débattent sur
le plateau d'Élise Lucay fallait-il que
je vous fe j'ai trois enfants donc deux
plus grands 19 et 16 ans et un plus
petit qui a 6 ans et j'ai été très
frappée parce que donc les trois on n
pas changé de quartier on est resté dans
la même école et à 10 ans d'intervalle
je n'ai pas reconnu la maternelle
c'est-à-dire que effectivement notre
fils revenait en disant que la journée
qu'est-ce que tu fais je cvaille je
travaille donc il y avait pas de jeu
donc j'ai d'abord pensé que c'était
peut-être 7 ma maîesse après je me suis
c'est peut-être cette école et puis j'ai
commencé à me renseigner j'ai rencontré
notamment des des chercheurs donc
Christophe
joignot qui est universitaire et qui et
qui faisait une étude sur justement le
l'utilisation des fiches en maternel et
comment voilà il y a de moins en moins
d'activités de manipulation d'activités
créatrices de dessins libre par exemple
il y en a quasiment plus
mais dès la moyenne section c'estàdire
que